ich möchte mal auf eine szene kommen die
ist relativ am anfang gegeben habt da
wurde nämlich christian lindner
angesprochen auf das was wolfgang
kubicki im interview mit uns bei bild
gesagt hat war natürlich zugegeben dass
er die krone regel nicht so ganz
beachtet hat und auch in der korona zeit
in die kneipe gegangen ist dass wir uns
einmal an wenn jetzt der fdp bundestags
vizepräsident kubicki gerade gesagt hat
er sei während des lok downs in illegal
geöffneter kneipen gegangen und das sei
auch sein recht gewesen was ist das für
ein signal die fdp hat eine ganz klare
haltung regeln müssen beachtet werden
wir haben fraglos eine etwas andere
abwägung als die kolleginnen und
kollegen bei der verhältnismäßigkeit von
freiheits eingriffen haben uns oft eine
andere balance zwischen
gesundheitsschutz und auch der achtung
von bürgerrechten gewünscht aber das
natürlich vollkommen zu trennen von der
radikalisierung die wir gegenwärtig
beobachten die muss man entschieden
zurückweisen und im übrigen auch unseren
staat ertüchtigen große gruppe was
glaubst du ist seit christi alister
vorgegangen als die frage kam und vier
männer sagen alles geht als er als er
gesehen hat was wolfgang kubicki so
losgetreten hatte ich wieder sorgen 13
rebounds
wer mit diesem interview sozusagen einen
kleinen molotow cocktail in dieser runde
platziert hat ich fand dass jetzt eine
schlechte antwort von lindner er drehte
sich hinter seinen parteikollegen
stellen müssen hätte sagen müssen wissen
sie
wie
kilos gehen um unsere partei schlechter
zu stellen ich sage ihnen einfach etwas
ich unterschreibe auch nicht das was er
kubicki sagte macht aber wissen sie im
zweifelsfall ist eben die fdp für die
freiheit und dann hätte ich mich endlich
etwas verteidigt aber was auch noch ein
punkt ist bereich können aber
ist das etwas was ihm jetzt gefährlich
werden kann weil die faz kommentiert
morgen verfassen uns feindlich über das
was wann kubica ist das jetzt
übertreiben nein also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen viele journalisten lassen
sich anstecken von dieser unglaublichen
dramatisierung sucht auch der politik
die reden da eine unglaubliche krise
herbei ich glaube nicht dass die leute
in deutschland jetzt das größte problem
darin besteht ob es herr kubicki in
einer kneipe war oder nicht aber was wir
sehen und was in diesen diskussionen
auch zum tragen gekommen ist ich finde
ganz wesentliche probleme sind gar nicht
angesprochen worden die die leute
beschäftigen ich habe man die
kriminalitätsstatistik angeschaut
gegenüber der zeit als ich noch hier
gearbeitet habe
gestiegene kriminalität vor allem auch
importierte kriminalität aufgrund dieser
sorglosen migrationspolitik ich glaube
die leute beschäftigt sehr stark dieses
migrations thema aber die journalisten
haben sich geeinigt wir reden nur über
klima wäre etwas über china ist auch
interessant aber ich finde wie eine
gewisse wieder realitätsflucht ist in
diesem gespräch auch zum tragen gekommen
und natürlich die traumatisierung lust
aber ich glaube nicht dass das das
größte problem dann möchte ich aber sage
einer dramatisierung lösen
und ohne dieses interview kubicki
genutzt tobi hat eine bestimmte swatch
kubicki ist ein im wortsinn jetzt freier
demokraten er ist rechtsanwalt
selbstständig er wohnt am rande
deutschlands in einer wunderschönen
gegend an der ostsee bisher lichter kann
die politik in deutschland und er tut
was er für richtig hält und er sagt
meine grundrechte lasse ich mich nicht
so ohne weiteres hinnehmen und das haben
ja viele andere auch gemacht ich könnte
hier auch ein bisschen was erzählen was
ich gegen die regeln gemacht habe weil
die regeln während der korona zeit zum
teil plötzlich nochmal bescheuert waren
ich habe es gab mal eine zeit lang da
konnte man nur ein gast empfangen zum
essen wie kannst du das machen wenn der
frei wartet dass das nur in holz und
nächste woche seine frau oder umgekehrt
ist doch bekloppt also natürlich haben
wir dann zu viert gegessen so dass alle
schweigen das apfel zu beißen
und da sage ich doch ich glaube
obwohl verwehungen war ein park sport
gemacht mein weg von dem man alles und
wirklich genutzt hat um sich er hat halt
ausgesprochen wie die meisten deutschen
gelebt haben ja an dem so ist und wie
die meisten menschen weil sie nämlich
auf ihr leben und sich selber besser
aufpassen können als der staat das
interpretiert haben und er hat das muss
man ja auch sagen bevor das auch in der
runde eine schieflage kriegt er hat
gesagt er war wir trinken mit kumpels an
einem ort mit einer inzidenz kein
kranker kein infizierter kein nichts
wind draußen alles mögliche und da ist
ein bier trinken gegangen und wenn der
dorfpolizist dazu gekommen wäre dann
hätte aber hätte er wahrscheinlich mit
lassen ist aber noch mal
aber tut das der fdp dass kubicki nicht
weh wenn die faz schreibt das ist
verfassungsfeindlich wenn sie sagen das
ist ein bundestags- vizepräsident recht
weil ich dann lese hat der klage seien
ich glaube das nicht weh tut ich glaube
dass hier sogar leute noch öffnet weil
nämlich der faz kommentar als bullshit
erkannt wird also wenn das
verfassungsfeindlich ist dass man ein
bierchen trinkt bei einer inzidenz mit
seinen kumpels in den bierkeller wenn
das verfassungsfeindlich ist dann
verhalten wir uns wahrscheinlich hätte
die politik ist es oft verlassen und die
vorbildfunktion die um die es da geht
ist ja nur ein verlogenes anhängsel denn
warum soll man denn dann nicht mit
seinen kumpels sozusagen einen trinken
gehen nur weil man der parlaments
vizepräsident ist ich glaube das hat 70
millionen menschen zustimmung und von
den zehn millionen können fünf die faz
gut finden aber über doch jetzt auch
nicht so dass wir ein regelbruch per se
feiern sollten war jetzt hat er die
regel gemacht und schon ist ein 1 1
doch es war richtig diesen regeln einige
feiern eine gesunde menschliche stand
eingekehrt ist in eine absurd hysterisch
habe ist illusion von der auch die
politik infiziert war um im wasser
bleiben der größte druck wir müssen als
bürger wir haben als bürger sogar die
pflicht darauf zu achten den gesetzgeber
und die regierung für unsinn abzuhalten
und das können wir nur durch unsere
stimme in der schon welcher gruppe und
wir können es ja kubicki hat jetzt
wieder mal eine wahrheits phase wo er
hat den hat den loriot
lauterbach einen starken genannt und da
kann ich nur sagen recht hat er
lauterbach ist ein spacken das heißt ja
das ist doch kein gutes benehmen oli
wieso denn ich möchte das land regieren
das ist doch mal aussprechen dass es
okay ist und dass menschen die uns ein
auswärtsspiel
du bist
jetzt sich zu wort dankeschön es ist
doch nicht so dass ein regelbuch per se
super ist und das ist doch auch nicht so
dass wenn politiker schimpfwörter
verwenden untereinander auch noch dass
das irgendwie uns alle gut aussehen
lässt ich finde das gut dass lindner ihn
heute eigentlich so ein bisschen durch
die hintertür gerückt hat und neue kann
der regel muss man sich halten doch er
hat eben auch anders machen können
ich weiß nicht was
dann bin ich ganz lange ruhig so
begriffen gebäudes würde bedeuten wenn
wir jetzt immer sagen man kann ruhig
regeln brechen weil die sind ja alle
quatsch dann kann ich auch bei rot über
die ampel fahren natürlich dass
wir etwas zusammen also was die was die
debatte an geht um den regelbruch bis
auf yvonne sagen glaube ich alle das ist
ganz okay eigentlich dass man noch in
die kneipe gegangen
es gibt einen punkt wo ich wo ich dich
unterstützen nun sank weil es gibt doch
einige leute die der meinung waren dass
diese extrem harten chor ohne regung
zwar bei der bevölkerung mit brutaler
konsequenz durchgesetzt werden aber die
politiker können ein bisschen machen was
sie wollen das haben wir in der schweiz
gesehen und auch zum teil den usa wie
news immer die schwersten lockt das in
kalifornien verordnung ist dann aber
selber mit freunden im restaurant oder
angebote in hanau gesehen könnte man
sagen das ist das problem aber bei
kubicki sehe ich was haben das war von
anfang an hatte er eigentlich immer
argumentiert und man könnte auch sagen
dass corona unita ich ein ganz großer
gewesen die gruppe geht es ja nicht in
kiel oder in berlin neukölln bei der das
restaurant sondern er hat gesehen das
ist ein bereich der ist incidents 0 und
da gehe ich jetzt eindringlich machte
einfach riesig männer herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einem die richtigen
fragen spezial und einer großen sparten
diskussion geworden du hast
du hast karl lauterbach in schutz
genommen
kubicki
kritisiert wie hast du das empfunden
diese spacken aussage in richtung
lauterbach ich finde tatsächlich dass
politiker eine verantwortung haben sich
so zu verhalten wie der rest des landes
sich verhalten soll und sonst niemand
stoppen also zum beispiel meint ich habe
beiden kindern sag ich immer bitte
benutzt keine schimpfwörter wie so
bringe ich ihnen das bei wenn unsere
höchsten staatsvertreter daran das war
aber dass dass bürger sich patricia wird
das frisst was ist deine meinung also
einmal zur kindererziehung will ich ganz
genau aber
ich muss halt mich hat es also insgeheim
ein bisschen amüsiert ich fand das mal
lustig war es war endlich mal was los
endlich mal was los wenn ich mal hat es
mal jemand aufgeregt und hat irgendwie
auch mal daneben gegriffen natürlich
kann man das nicht machen das ist
natürlich völlig klar aber es hat eben
auch was authentisches zumindest hast du
da keine zweifel was für eine meinung
hat kubicki wohnen über das muss ich mal
sagen wenn man wenn man das wahrnimmt
bei sich selbst und bei vielen menschen
gern umgeben was die zudem karl
lauterbach so sagen den der einem jedes
jede woche 45 mal begegnet mit
irgendeinem ruf nach verschärfung der
korona maßnahmen und das seit ungefähr
anderthalb jahren was sagt man zudem das
was mir da durch den kopf geht möchte
ich lieber jetzt nicht sagen wie gar
nicht und deshalb spacken ist für mich
ein vornehmes
schimpfwort von nerven netzwerk gegeben
hat so genau weiß das ist zu wenig von
dem niemand so genau weiß was es
bedeutet und deshalb ist es ein
wunderbares wort für kinder ich habe
immer die halbseitig spacken stadt
irgendwie andere schiffe zu
kindererziehung
freunde jetzt wirklich nicht noch
einfacher sein als der papst könnte es
überhaupt genau natürlich erzählen
brechen die kinder natürlich jetzt sieht
man seine kinder dazu keine
schimpfwörter zu sagen aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass wenn dein mann mit
seinem sohn ein hsv spiel anschaut und
es eskaliert und es ist spannend und ein
hsv-spieler was ja häufiger vorkommt
verdoppelt eine riesenchance die sich
zurück banken ja ja und ich sage nicht
so ein ungelenker spieler ich sage ganz
so ein verdammt das packen und trotzdem
haben sie sein trikot und trotzdem
lieben sie den und trotzdem ist es ein
toller fußball spielen
darf ich dieser übersetzung war in
bayern ist das eher
dezent depp ist außerhalb bayerns klingt
es wie er sei ausser man denkt oh johnny
depp ist es sozusagen ein maximales
schon vor den bayern sagt nein das
selbst und mails eigentlich befreundet
genau wie man sagt du hin und es klingt
außerhalb bayerns furchtbar und das ist
eine norddeutsche begriff spacken es
gibt sogar mode linien moin ihr spacken
wir also ich
würde man in der schweiz spaten
übersetzen
was man so sagen
wenn das jemand zu dir sagen würde es
lieben
ihr dürft euch jetzt nicht meinen
politiker doch noch auf ein podest
stellen als moralisches vorbild und
beziehungsform wenn wir die heutige
runde gesehen haben diese sterile
diskussion um diese sieben zum teil in
perfektem bühnen hochdeutsch
artikulieren dem
fachpolitiker jargon dann ist doch ein
kubicki sozusagen ein meilenstein der
der authentizität in die suite des
gefühls beruhigte im gefriergetrockneten
gesprächsatmosphäre
zweitens gibt es riesige emotionen der
größte regelbruch aus meiner sicht ist
die korona politik herr laut aber auch
ich möchte nicht zu nahe treten aber der
gehört zu den experten die an dieser
runde auch schon kritisiert wurden die
immer wieder einfach noch mal einen
drauf geben die das gefühl haben sie
müssen das land beherrschen und dass da
ein gewisser politiker einem ventil
funktion auto noch irgendeinen ausdruck
verwendet denn nicht sauber fähig ist
und was mich an der politik viel mehr
ärgert ist diese sogenannte salonfähige
verlogenheit diese diese engelszungen
spreche da immer diesen perfekten
austarierten singsang aber wenn die
kamera nicht mehr läuft damit rum
geflucht und rumgemacht und da ist
einfach eine gewisse authentizität zu
reden die leute er hat doch noch ein
bisschen wein getrunken vielleicht auch
vorher schon vor dem interview ein
zweites glas wein wissen aber ich finde
das auch erfrischend und hört auf diese
politiker dazu überschätzen oder also
ich erziehe meine kinder aber nicht
meine politik also nicht die politiker
und ja aber die aber oft nicht zu hohe
griechenland ja ja klar das ist insofern
kann ich von denen auch es wird doch
nichts zu schweben ich würde uns einem
deutschland erhöht das nicht roller
schick auf den sound sorgen ich würde
das nicht zu schwer nehmen jetzt mit dem
komme ich nehme das nicht schwer aber
ich feiere erst auch nicht dass es sein
und es ist wirklich kein richtig böses
wort es ist kein böses deshalb hat das
ja verwendet und er sagt ja auch nicht
er selber hält ihn für ein spaten
sondern er sagt hat freunde da oben in
seiner gegend mit denen er redet halten
lauterbach in denen ihnen ein spacken
internet
[Musik]